Republicans are fighting back against
the left spaceless impeachment sham
today Senate Judiciary member Josh
Hawley senator Hawley proposed the
measure to dismiss the House articles of
impeachment if they are not sent to the
Senate within 25 calendar days of their
adoption which was December the 18th and
Senate Judiciary Chairman Lindsey Graham
who will be with us tomorrow has given
speaker Pelosi an ultimatum sent over
the articles by the end of the week or
he will work with Mitch McConnell to
start the impeachment trial without her
permission
joining us now senator Josh Hawley first
I want to applaud you the idea that oh
we're just gonna hold them indefinitely
oh we're gonna lecture the Senate on how
they will do their business as if that
constitutional authority somehow but
falls on them or arguing that the
president is not the commander in chief
this is important that means that if I
read my dates are right that this case
can be disposed of in a lot by January
11th am I reading that right yeah that's
right this is day 19 Sean and this is so
important because the the House Speaker
is trying to run the United States
Senate she's trying to hijack the trial
she's trying to obstruct the trial and
in so doing she's really subverting the
Constitution because the Constitution is
clear says the house has the power to
impeach they've done that wrong decision
but they've done it the Senate has the
power to try the case and it's time for
the Senate to fight back what happened
to all that urgency that it had to be
done in record time yeah exactly you
know we heard nothing but how urgent it
was the president be removed what a
national security threat he was whenever
that was supposed to mean and now all of
a sudden no urgency at all and I think
with that show Sean is the only urgency
on the part of the Democrats in Pelosi
was an urgency to pursue their personal
vendetta against the President of the
United States they never accepted his
election they never wanted him in office
they wanted to get him out but now when
it's time to put up or shut up and
actually put their evidence forward
they're afraid to do it because they
don't have any evidence it's a sham it's
a joke it's a fraud so they had all
their witnesses that it's their job to
impeach then house managers supposedly
supposed to present their case before
the Senate based on what they came up
with
now they're talking about no we want to
add all these other witnesses that they
didn't call or fight to get to me
they're asking now the Senate to do the
job they should have done now at the end
of the day when you eliminate opinion
witnesses and hearsay witnesses you only
have one fact witness and that was
ambassador Sandlin what did the
president want nothing I want no quid
pro quo so to me it's a slam dunk and
the idea also of an obstruction charge
when there is a conflict between the
executive and legislative branch and
they seek remedy in the other branch of
government known as the judiciary and
the Supreme Court is reviewing that
that's not reason for obstruction no it
never has a been shown in the past and
look they have no they have no case and
they know it and that's why they're
afraid to proceed to a trial the Senate
is ready to have a trial the president
deserves to have a trial the American
people deserve a trial so we can put
this thing to rest and now Speaker
Pelosi wants to have this go on for who
knows how long here's the thing shot in
the nineteen days it could be 90 days I
mean she'll it'll never end unless we
take action now they want to live in a
constant state of impeaching the
president I got that if he cured cancer
they didn't peach him for that I say it
all the time here's the thing where's
Mitt Romney
where is Murkowski where is Lamar
Alexander where's Susan Collins well I
can't speak for anybody but myself but I
tell you this Sean when I introduce my
resolution today we immediately got 10
co-sponsors in the Senate including
members of leadership the people that I
talked to in the Senate my colleagues
they're very frustrated they're sick and
tired of what the house is doing they're
sick and tired of the Democrats antics
and they're ready to stand up for the
Constitution and I believe they will
good for you senator great job and
between you and Lindsey Graham and
others I do believe that we're talking
about the presidency this is not a game
and they have now lowered the bar for
impeachment basically it's spitting on
the sidewalk or jaywalking thank you for
being with us